if you instead design an electric car to
just be very efficient all those
problems go away efficiency is the magic
key to making electric cars better and
it is ridiculously overlooked in modern
car design
hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
in December of 2022 a remarkable event
would cause underground murmurs in the
automotive industry a Little Dutch
company called light here had done the
impossible an electric car that could
drive for months without needing to be
charged and it wasn't a concept car it
was actively being delivered to
customers what it was was indeed the
world's first production solar family
car although it sounds too good to be
true it actually does prove that the
solar car audio isn't as implausible as
it seems there are some compromises
though it was ridiculously expensive but
the idea was solid and if further
developed it could be an amazing future
sadly though as soon as the excitement
started around the new achievement it
was essentially over light year declared
bankruptcy so what went wrong and also
there's a last minute twist to the story
so be sure to stick around for that
you are watching tele Fusion TV
[Music]
solar-powered cars largely remained a
distant dream despite numerous
technological advancements the concept
is fascinating the idea of having a
virtually infinite power source that
doesn't cost anything to fuel however
the industry still faces hurdles
overall solar panels aren't very
efficient at their maximum consumer
solar panels can get up to about 22
efficiency but they're also heavy and
relatively expensive
a solar film on the other hand is a lot
cheaper and lighter but it's less
efficient usually below 15 percent and
this becomes a great engineering
challenge finding the balance between
efficiency cost and weight moreover
these cars must absolutely sit power in
order to be viable despite these
obstacles promising designs are moving
closer to the mainstream with each
passing year and there was one company
that stood above them all
thank you
the origins of light here go back to
2013 in the Australian Outback of all
places this is the location of the
annual Bridgestone World solar challenge
the event is as it sounds different
teams compete to drive across the
Australian desert a distance of three
thousand kilometers or 1900 miles
all the way from Darwin in the north to
Adelaide in the south
it's a timed event with checkpoint
sections whoever crosses the Finish Line
first wins
a team of engineering students at the
Technical University of einhoven in the
Netherlands brought their car to the
event they named the car Stella in 2013
was going to be its debut
it boasted a top speed of 120 kilometers
an hour or 75 miles per hour and could
seat four people the vehicle won first
place in their category in 2015 the team
won again but this time they even had
the vehicle legally registered in 2017
they won again
interestingly in the context of a full
year of operation the car was so energy
efficient that it was energy net
positive but this feat can even be
achieved intraday the IEEE Spectrum
Journal reports quote what might be most
impressive about the Stellar Lux is that
it's energy positive on average the car
uses less energy driving than it
produces during the day even in a place
like the Netherlands where it's not
constantly Sunny depending on the
weather the daily driving range of the
car and solar power alone varies between
50 and 300 kilometers and driving any
less than the daily Max solar range
results in a surplus of energy that can
be returned to the grid end quote
the team obviously knew their stuff and
thought that they could take this idea
even further so later that year five of
the students from the University team
launched the light year company
the goal was simple they were going to
produce the world's first commercially
viable solar family car it wasn't going
to be easy though crossing the
Australian outback is one thing but how
do you Mass produce such a vehicle what
about safety standards and government
regulations this would surely add to the
cost and weigh down the car but the idea
of a car that charges itself was too
good to let go of
[Music]
car now dump the light year zero was
announced in mid-2019 and started
production in 2021 after raising 110
million dollars in funding they began
selling in early 2022
if you live in a sunny City environment
and only drive for sure periods it could
be a great fit and that's what thousands
of people thought when they dropped 296
000 US Dollars on the car it was going
to be available in the EU Switzerland
Norway and they're even not so Sunny UK
here's a clip from the YouTube channel
the fully charged show showing the car
in operation
right we are out on the road in the very
nearly production ready light year zero
this is a bit surreal this has been a
long time coming this moment I think my
first impression is that I'm very aware
that I'm driving a really really
efficient car because the car is making
sure that I'm aware of that fact on this
screen in the middle here I can see
exactly what my solar panels are doing
there's no point building a
hyper-efficient car if you're not going
to then encourage people to treat it
properly and drive it properly and this
car very obviously wants to be driven in
an efficient way
some of our less technically inclined
viewers may be wondering why are light
years so obsessed with efficiency
well currently the popular method for
giving an electric car big range is by
giving it a really big battery but doing
so has negative knock-on effects on cost
weight and about a million other things
but if you instead design an electric
car to just be very efficient all those
problems go away an efficient EV can
make do with a smaller battery which
makes it cheaper to buy cheaper to run
lighter better to drive quicker to
charge and ultimately kinder to the
planet to name just a few of the
benefits put simply efficiency is the
magic key to making electric cars better
and it is ridiculously overlooked in
modern car design
the light year zero is a sleek and
somewhat futuristic looking sedan it
incorporates five square meters of solar
panels into the body and this all feeds
into a 61.2 kilowatt hour battery
capable of a range of 625 kilometers or
388 miles the power output of the car is
130 kilowatts
the light year zero is covered in a
thousand solar panels under ideal
conditions the solar panels covering the
hood and the Fastback roof can chip in
up to 1.05 kilowatts of constant trickle
charging
in essence it's a plug-in solar hybrid
some cities can have over 150 days of
sunshine per year City driving in these
locations could see you drive 60
kilometers per day just from the Sun
alone effectively for certain periods of
the Year you'd never have to charge the
car sure 60 kilometers isn't a massive
distance but I still think that's pretty
cool
but because the car is so efficient the
performance is well emaciated
the top speed is 160 kilometers an hour
or 99 miles an hour and it has slow
acceleration with a 0-60 time of 10
seconds but those are the sacrifices you
have to make for efficiency
on the interior it seats five people and
has a 10.1 inch touchscreen there are so
many interesting things about this car
even down to the countries that make it
it is a rare European Affair a Dutch
company whose car is built in Finland
and designed in Italy
[Music]
overall things were looking good for the
light year company and they were in pole
position for a revolution but in January
2023 there was a shock announcement
light year announced that they were
halting the production of the xero model
and redirecting their efforts towards
the production of the light year 2. the
light year 2 is a more affordable
version of their Vision Atlas
Technologies the subsidiary that was
responsible for the manufacturing of the
light year zero would be allowed to go
bankrupt there was expected to be 600
job losses nobody actually knew much
about the Light Year too and the
bankruptcy of the manufacturing
contractor was a huge shock to the
community was the dream over so quickly
what happened
the reasons for bankruptcy aren't clear
just yet but ultimately turning an
experimental vehicle into a mass-market
product was either a more difficult or B
more expensive than originally estimated
there were plenty of overhead costs
designing tooling manufacturing testing
paying staff and you name it that's a
lot of costs and the money coming in was
only pre-orders and external investors
but soon the investment would dry up
we can't ignore the economic timing as
2022 started to wrap up light year was
walking into an economic storm that
would take down their business
in 2020 fearing deflation from covert
lockdowns central banks panicked and
drove interest rates to zero and printed
money obviously prices started Rising as
a consequence
to combat this central banks started
raising interest rates sharply starting
in the middle of 2022 Rising interest
rates made investment funds harder to
come by the very same funds that a
capturally intensive startup like
Lightyear needed to function add to this
supply chain disruptions from the war in
Ukraine also driving up material costs
ultimately this all proved too much for
light year and they bowed out
the light year story isn't over just yet
but before we get back to them let's
explore some of the other recent solar
car efforts
foreign
weren't the only ones to suffer this
fate too the company Sono was planning
to release the Scion a plug-in solar
hybrid car which could travel 189 miles
on the charge the Scion's body was
completely covered in 456 solar cells
although less visually pleasing the idea
was popular there were over 19 000
reservations at a cost of thirty
thousand dollars but it wasn't to be in
December of 2022 the company announced
that they were unable to raise enough
Capital they resorted to crowdfunding to
help their project but by February 2023
this had also failed and the plans to
manufacture were canceled
aptero is another effort in this space
although they're a little more
unconventional
what they're planning is a two-seater
three-wheeled vehicle the range is an
impressive 1000 miles or 1 600
kilometers
they achieved this by using a
lightweight resin and composite
materials as well as a very
aerodynamically efficient design
the vehicle has two 50 kilowatt wheel
hub Motors and requires less than 100
watt hours of energy per mile that's
about 2.5 times more energy efficient
than a Tesla Model 3.
the solar panels on the vehicle can add
an extra 66 kilometers or 41 miles per
day from sunlight under ideal conditions
this once again means that drivers May
seldom have to recharge their vehicles
the price range is from 25 900 to 47 000
all versions have an electronic speed
limit of 180 kilometers an hour or 110
miles per hour over 30 000 vehicles have
been reserved and this was worth about
one billion dollars in sales they aim to
have their first deliveries in 2024 and
begin to ramp up production in 2025.
we'll see if this one happens
so a last minute twist to this story
instead of packing up and going home
light here are going to give it another
go they're back in business the light
year company is in the process of
restructuring their assets the new
Arrangement will be a trimmed down
version of their company the focuses
strictly on the more affordable light
year 2. in the deal lightly will form a
new company and put up their
intellectual property as collateral if
the company fails again investors can
walk away with this IP and use it within
another company that they think is
better managed the light year 2 is said
to be releasing in 2025 for 40 000 US
Dollars the company has 21 000
pre-orders but the thing is this low
price is not a Guarantee Supply Chain
issues may affect the cost of raw
materials but it's still going to be
cheaper than the original model
according to the CEO so how is it so
much cheaper well again according to
their CEO the light year zero costs so
much because it was designed for a
limited production and a lot of elements
for the production process were custom
made the team is bringing the technology
learned from the light year zero down to
the light year 2. but this doesn't fully
explain it for me so I think perhaps
they've also cut down operation costs
and moved the manufacturing out of
Europe
ultimately it's a bit of a question mark
and it remains to be seen for me
surprisingly the light year 2 is a
bigger car being more of an SUV platform
Lightyear co-founder Lex host flip
speaks quote this is great news all
involved worked relentlessly to secure
the continuation of our mission we kept
the interests of all stakeholders at
Heart during the process we realized
that the impact on our employees
investors clients and suppliers is
significant but we tried to find the
best way forward for everyone end quote
is high stakes for the company because
the lenders may have the right to seize
and sell off IP assets if there are more
money problems if this happens the light
year team will be done for good
so in conclusion these cars don't solve
every problem facing the advancement of
solar powered travel they are not some
miracle but they do act as a proof of
concept and I think it's a fantastic
step in the right direction the
engineering team behind Lightyear have
proved themselves by winning multiple
solar competitions but as we've seen to
mass produce these cars is challenging I
honestly admire the effort and I think
it's so cool that Engineers are daring
to do something that's so difficult it's
clear to see that as solar technology
improves we'll be seeing it more and
more in fact Toyota's new Prius has a
solar panel on the roof that can add up
to four miles of charge per day
I'm wishing the light year Team all the
best and even if they don't make it in
the Solar automotive industry I hope
someone else does with a little more
time the solar-powered revolution could
just be around the corner
so I'll pose the question to you if you
could pick up a solar car for around 30
000 US Dollars and you can get an extra
50 kilometers of range or 30 miles of
range per day just from the Sun but it
happened to be pretty slow would you get
one I'll be interested to know your
thoughts
some quick housekeeping before I wrap
this video up my second episode in
collaboration with the Australian
Broadcasting Corporation is live in it I
explore the intersection of AI and
education and is it still worth getting
a University degree in the coming age of
AI it's an interesting topic so I'll
leave a link down in the description
below and a huge thank you to those of
you who commented on the last episode
seeing all of your positive reactions
makes everything worth it so thank you
alright so that's about it from me my
name is dagogo and you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll catch you again
soon for the next episode cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
thank you
it's new thinking